- Aux grands maux
les grandes installations
pour recevoir les négoci
du monde entier qui participent
à la 15e Conférence des parties
à la Convention sur la diversité
biologique des Natioeseseses,
la COP15.
Une rencontre en haut lieu,
pour discuter d'un sujet
sérieux : rieninininins
que de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité.
"Sur les 8 millions d'espèces
vivantes connues, 1 million
sont menacées d'extinction
d'ici la fin du siècle",
rappelle la secrétaire générale
de la Convention sur
la diversité biologique.
Et selon les scientifiques,
la crise du vivant à l'échelle
planétaire a atteint
son paroxysme.
50 % des coraux sont disparus;
66 % de l'environnement marin
est dégradé, tout comme
75 % des terres.
"Notre vied d d d de
la biodiversité; c'est
la nourriture que nous mangeons,
l'air que nous respirons,
l'eau usususus buvons.
Elle permet de réguler le climat
et de produire des médicaments",
précise-t-elle.
isisisise qui concerne tous et
chacun, même le secteur privé,
alors que les économistes
estiment que la moitié du PIB
mondial dépend de la nature.
- C'est probablement la COP
la plus importante de l'histoire
des COP en biodiversité.
- Comme plusieurs, l'émissaire
aux changements climatiques
du Québec voit dans cette COP15
l'occasion à saisir
pour freiner la débâcle
et élaborer un cadre mondial
pour la prochaine décennie.
JEAN LEMIRE, émissaire, chang.
clim. et enjeux noctctctct., Qc
- On va essayer d'abord
d'avoir des règles de protection
de la nature, donc essayer
de protéger 30 % de la planète
et des o C C C Ça, c'est
un grand défi. On va également
parler d'agriculture :
comment est-ce qu'on on va
pratiquer notre agriculture?
- Les acteurs de la société
civile, eux, profiteront de
l'occasion pour faire pression
sur les gouvernements.
ALAIN BRANCHAUD, DG, Société
pour la nature et les parcs, Qc
- Québec et Ottawa annoncent
l'agrandissement du parc marin
du Saguenay-Saint-Laurent
pour la protection du béluga.
C'est un modèle qui foneeee
bien. C'est un beau modèle
de collaboration, un beau modèle
de gouvernance pour une aire
protégée.
- Et ielelelelle que
la biodiversité joue un rôle
de premier plan pour contrer
la crise climatique.
- Donc, on estime de 30 à 40 %ls
pour lutter contre le climat
d'ici 2030. Et leur meilleur
séquestreur de carbone,
c'est les arbres, là,
qu'on a autour de nous.
- On espère accoucher
d'un accord aussi important
que celui de l'Accord de Paris
pour le climat. Manenenenerf
de la guerre reste l'argent
et, avec le bilan mitigé
de la COP27 en Égypte,
plusieurs pequququque la partie
est loin d'être gagnée.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa